[Music]
this is a Reddit post maybe relationship
advice or something but it goes I'm
autistic and my special interest is
cheating on my
wife hello I'm an autic Chan user posted
this I know I know hello I'm an autistic
male and through some assistance I have
been able to find assistance what and
through some assistance I have been able
to find assistance and a relationship
with a woman that I am very happy with
however I have a hyper fixation with
cheating on my wife that has replaced
thank you should have thrown it not
going I'm not going to Obie's like I'm
better than that you don't have to be
though I have a hyper fixation with
cheating on my wife that has replaced my
interest in cargo
liners what's a cargo liner uh isn't
that like a type of pants or something
oh no no no I think it's a ship or
something I constantly think of
schematics on how to get away with
cheating on my wife and I have
successfully pulled such Heist multiple
times as I have carefully coordinated
methods without my wife having the
slightest inkling of doubt I'm not
buying this I don't enjoy the sex all
that much I just am amazed I've been
able to successfully cheat 12 times
without anyone noticing I think this is
considered evil that is why I'm posting
it here no do God forbid men have fun
stupid this is just some bro trying to
cover off no I'm just like on the
Spectrum or whatever so it's my special
interest you know yeah
yeah I don't know I'm just obsessed with
cheating but it's not my it's not my
fault my I was born this way I was born
to cheat babe it's my ADHD acting up
yeah
exactly yeah weak troll so alen and I
were eating this weekend eating some
sushi and this redditor couple through
and through sits down next to us uh the
wife shows up first and she brings a New
York Magazine is reading it at the sushi
Wine Bar while she waits for her husband
okay and uh the bartender walks up and
he
goes hey can I get you anything
started and she's like I will have a
this drink and he goes uh you you
expecting someone and then she
goes yeah he'll have a this he's my
husband I should
know okay it's all ready off to you can
feel it and the bartender is like all
right okay you know the drinks and you
know she's over there hucking and
chucking I used to work in the service
industry you know just be beating him
down and with comments and the husband
arrives and he goes has arrived yet he
goes what is this a bacon
Martini anyone seen the
Narwhal no that'd be too that'd be too
swap
yeah right no this guy shows up and he's
like what did I
miss that is his voice that voice is so
good that is his voice okay so you know
they start uh wait what was she saying
to the bartender like what what kind of
comments was she so after the comments
she just went to reading okay but then
when she started speaking up you know
she's well so here's what happened I go
to take a whiz and while I was
gone uh classic you know uh Texas dude
our
left who was just saying wild stuff to
his girlfriend you know he's like look
he's like looking at her phone some of
the quotes were oh yeah you were thicker
back
then show me your body show me some pics
of your body just just showing him nudes
basically at the wine bar so while I'm
gone this this dude from Texas this
these are direct quotes you know oh yeah
you were thicker back then show me your
body those are direct quotes Okay he
held up a plate and said there is hair
on it there's a white hair on my plate
and it seemed very targeted because the
uh person working the wine bar our
waitress working alongside the other
bartender
waiter she had you know she was she was
a gray fox okay she's a big grayed in
the hair MH she had it was white and
gray mix so it felt like he was
targeting her no there was a white hair
in my food okay he you can't see that
can't see that it gets really awkward
the redditor husband no this this is the
this is the Texas guy and it's getting
uncomfortable he's chirping he's getting
aggressive and you know she says well do
I I can just take it off it's you know
it's fine do do you want it remade he's
like
nah just being kind of harsh so then I
come back from the whz and so what I
walk
into is the redditor
going well the customer's always right
for Taste but they're not always right
and then his wife is chiming in I get it
you know I worked in the service
industry for many many years and I know
you just build that habit of saying I'm
sorry and you're not even sorry but you
just you have a tendency to say it you
know yeah just like that okay and then
the redditor is going off about you know
that's the thing with you know and he
just yapping about food and stuff food
arrives and I tune his ass out like I'm
just enjoying this right
here and then and your food arrives and
it's like a silver hair roll mhm it's
tuna wrapped in silver hair and I'm like
ooh what's this these are the gray fox
noodles so I eat I'm loving it having a
great time Texas dude out of nowhere
just kind of drunkenly barks at me get
the F
Gua and I
went you're not getting me with that bro
yeah yeah thanks but I was like all
right dude F [__] fua what are you trying
to say what are you trying to say what
are you trying to say man who the [__]
you calling
fua bro is that French or something I'm
from La bro don't talk to me like that
no I'm saying get the foga yeah all
right man let's chill let's chill on
that you
know um so then the redditor hits the
greatest line I heard all weekend what
did he
say you
know this dish makes me want to work
hard so I can afford to eat this dish
every day said that really verbatim to
the waiter to the waiter well because
they they were bartenders waiters and
the guy is just kind of leaning over the
counter and he's
like
[__] why
me
why did you have to say that to
me and he's just like yeah yeah totally
yeah he's really trying to he's walking
away as he's serving food yeah
yep
yeah
uhhuh yeah and this guy just you
know the thing about the service
industry is just all this the whole time
just that
yeah this dish makes me want to work
hard every day so I can afford it which
is you know it's beautiful but shut the
[__]
up that's the moral of the story you
know it's just nobody gives a [__] yeah
awesome but please shut the [__] up yeah
you can think that yeah and that's great
whatever motivates you say that in your
hands in your car yeah
yeah I want to work
hard I can you know say that to your
wife as you guys bacon narwhal out of
there man it was so just Millennial
redditor this dish makes me want to work
hard every day so I can afford to eat it
every day oh thank you for the gold kind
stranger